[Musique]
il s'agit de d'apporter des chansons à
domicile d'être des messages un peu
comme des livreurs de fleurs de pizza
sushi sauf colère il s agisse de
chansons ça va de jane très récents ou à
schubert en passant par david bowie
dalida j'ai libéré délivré par exemple
qui marche très très bien avec le
deuxième tome de la reine des neiges les
chansons ne sont pas gratuites elles
sont offertes pas avare macal qui via
nous nous offre la possibilité d'offrir
une chanson gratuitement je vous invite
à vous jeter sur cette occasion de faire
un cadeau qui restera mémorable
pendant de longues années il nous arrive
quelquefois de revoir des personnes qui
ont reçu une chanson et qui s'en
souviennent encore parce que c'est
c'est unique et à plus forte raison en
ce moment c'est tout à fait particulier
et nous resterons les gestes barrière
est évidemment